wie sie wissen hat sich die
bedrohungslage etwas geändert nach den
anschlägen in deutschland und in nizza
haben wir natürlich auch darauf reagiert
und erstmals führen wir bei der airpower
2016 eine lückenlose personenkontrolle
beim zutritt durch
man kann nie etwas ausschließen aber wir
haben uns versucht auf alle möglichen
und unmöglichen szenarien vorzubereiten
das schwergewicht des einsatzes des
polizeilichen einsatzes liegt im
verkehrsbereich ist während
veranstaltungen vor allem daran gemessen
wie gut das verkehrskonzept umgesetzt
worden ist und daher legen wir unser
schwergewicht bereits in der planung in
die verkehrslenkung und
verkehrsüberwachungsmaßnahmen bei der
einsatzplanung gehen gefährdungsanalysen
voraus und die allgemeine
sicherheitslage erfordert
einfach dass man das bei den einsatz
konzepten berücksichtigt wir müssen auch
polizeilicherseits rücksicht nehmen auf
die organisationen des veranstalters und
daher unsere konzepte entsprechend
anpassen
es gibt ja diese enge zusammenarbeit mit
der polizei auf drei ebenen
ich habe einen meiner offiziere als
verbindungselement in den krisenstab des
militärkommandos abgestellt mein
ansprechpartner ist der
polizeikommandant des bezirkes mutter
die hauptaufgabe der militärstreife
unter unterstellten teile hier bei
dieser veranstaltung ist die sicherheit
im veranstaltungsgelände
die größte herausforderung ist dass sich
bei dieser erbauer das bundesheer mit
sicherheit als maßgeblicher sicherheits
provider etabliert und zu diesem zweck
sind wir neben den angehörigen der
militärstreife militärpolizei auch
andere elemente unterstellt die mit
denen wir gemeinsam einen wesentlichen
beitrag zur sicherheit dieser
veranstaltung leisten zum beispiel eine
gemischte panzer kompanie grenadier
fahrzeuge und auch die elemente und zwei
jäger kommen
der unterschied von uns zu einer zivilen
feuerwehr ist mir die lösch kapazität
wir haben wir zwei mal 5000 liter wasser
mit vor ort draußen und es sind 90
sekunden das ist eine zeitvorgabe
wir müssen innerhalb von 90 sekunden
egal wo am flughafen
das löschwasser am verunfallten
luftfahrzeug aufbringen
wir üben das speziell dreimal im jahr in
allen stecken da haben ein großer
spielplatz für feuerwehren sorgen können
wir mit kerosin löschen anfangen ich bin
der chef dass seine truppe bei dieser
erbauer dies ungefähr 240 mann und frau
stark und die aufgaben sind die
versorgung sämtlicher mitarbeiter aller
ausländischen mitarbeiter die die
pflegen und am veranstaltungstag des
gesamten besuchs wir haben alle schon
erlebt herzinfarkt schlaganfall
frühgeburt bestrebung verletzungen
komplizierte weniger komplizierte wir
müssen uns auf uns einstellen weil es
kommen die besucher von zwei jahren bis
90 jahren ja das ist die die maschine
als eigentlich alle drei die version
notarzt mäßig das heißt mit der
maschinen kann man einen patienten der
wirklich notfall wichtig ist bergen
versorgen und zu rein versorgung bringen
in das entsprechende krankenhaus gut sie
kann über land es gibt keinen ort wo die
nicht landen kann